if super freaky girl is a pop song what
song is
big energy so I'ma say it again because
I know people like to twist my words if
super freaky girl is pop then so is Big
energy it's a war of words between Nicki
Minaj and Lotto I'm not bad this is
crazy
the bee fall started on Thursday when
Nikki went on Insta live to talk about
how her track super freaky girl has been
moved into pop categories at the Grammys
[Music]
super freaky girl where I only wrapped
on the song was removed out of rap
categories at the Grammys right and put
in pop that's when the musician pointed
out that her song was taken out of rap
categories while lotto's big energy was
not big energy is rap but super freaky
girl let's pop
now if you say both of them are Pop I
would say okay fine because I'm all
about being fair keep in mind not only
did Lotto refer to Big energy as a pop
song on Twitter but Nikki pointed out
that big energy and super freaky girl
even have the same producers before
accusing the recording Academy of moving
the goal post in order to uplift people
they want to shine
[Music]
the people who control things a lot of
things behind the scene
they have to elevate someone that they
profit off
so they must move the goal post
for me all the time
well Lotto caught wind of all that and
responded on Twitter writing quote damn
I can't win for losing all these Awards
knobs and I can't even celebrate and
that's when things really heated up with
Nikki sharing this screenshot of an
alleged DM from Lotto agreeing with her
it is the real world you're about to go
head on into the real world and while
Lotto said she looked up to Nikki and
didn't want to go back and forth online
the drama was just getting started with
Nikki calling Lotto a Karen for agreeing
with her in private but not publicly
speaking up and Lotto accusing Nikki of
shading her on social media in the past
even attempting to share some receipts
which Nikki's fans were quick to
discredit claiming they had nothing to
do with Lotto well thank you Nikki
slammed Lotto for bringing her name up
in interviews calling her scratch off
while Lotto referred to Nikki as super
freaky Grandma adding you're asking why
I didn't speak up in your defense it's
the same answer I gave you when you
asked why I didn't congratulate you
you're literally older than my mom
trying to be a bully girl you better not
Nikki posted several different
screenshots where Lotto allegedly asked
the Anaconda rapper to sing on her
tracks all of which Nikki declined I
mean it's pretty obvious
Lotto not only through shade back she
threw the whole tree tweeting more but
this time about Nikki's loved ones first
Lotto called out Nikki's husband Kenneth
Petty who was convicted of attempted
first degree rape and then she brought
up Nikki's brother Jelani Mirage who's
serving 25 years to life in prison after
being convicted of a predatory sexual
assault against a child Nikki responded
to the Jabs tweeting that Lotto didn't
care about rape when she was begging for
features and added it's dangerous to
weaponize rape and while it's unclear if
the two have made peace after their
explosive exchange Nikki has since
deleted a majority of her tweets to
Lotto
[Music]